on passe tout de suite là notre second
débat volontairement vous le savez
décalée de l'actualité
c'est vraiment notre volonté tous les
soirs il est consacré à la chasse
plusieurs accidents ont relancé la
question de la sécurité une pétition sur
ce thème sur l'encadrement a même été
lancée sur le site du sénat mais quand
on parle d'un loisir qui mobilise
plusieurs millions de passionnés c'est
aussi un électorat très convoité flora
sauvage c'est un électorat très courtisé
à la proche de la présidentielle plus
d'un million de français possèdent un
permis de chasse et à droite de marine
le pen à eric zemmour en passant par les
as l'air les chasseurs sont une cible
prioritaire moi je continuerai à me
battre pour qu'il puisse conserver cette
tradition ces chasses traditionnelles
si elles sont régulièrement malmenée je
pense que ça fait partie aussi formes de
patrimoine de votre pays à gauche le
sujet divise alors que la chasse
provoque en moyenne la mort de 19
personnes par an le candidat écologiste
à la présidentielle yannick jadot
veulent interdire durant les week-ends
et les vacances scolaires on a encore eu
un accident un promeneur en haute savoie
qui a pris une balle à côté d'un
cimetière il va falloir que la nature
soit accessible à tout le monde pour le
candidat communiste à la présidentielle
fabien roussel les chasseurs sont
essentielles à la préservation de notre
environnement
chez moi il ya une surpopulation de
sangliers et donc tous les ans c'est la
préfecture qui fait appel aux chasseurs
pour
réviser surpopulation sortie un argument
que réfute willy schraen le président de
la fédération nationale des chasseurs
on est là pour réguler alors oui mais
c'est ce que j'espère mais t'as pas
compris ah bah alors si vous n'êtes pas
qu'on n'a pas compris que nous c'est une
passion et ben alors a compris qu'on
prend du plaisir dans l'acte face à tuer
ça en fait partie alors que la chasse
est le troisième loisirs préférés des
français en nombre de licenciés près de
5 millions de personnes ont déjà
pratiqué c'est un électorat dont
emmanuel macron a toujours pris soin
l'une des premières mesures de son
quinquennat fut de diviser par deux le
prix du permis de chasse
faut-il mieux encadrer la chasse dans la
tête de notre débat avec thierry costes
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
obi ce conseiller politique de la
fédération française de la chasse
guillaume gontard bonsoir bonsoir
sénateur de l'isère président du groupe
écologiste
solidarité voilà voilà faire dire
écologistes comme ça tout le monde de
quoi on parle il faudrait que dans les
bons soirs vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste des questions
d'environnement parmi les livres que
vous avez publié il ya celui ci la
chasse le vrai du faux c'est aux
éditions delachaux et niestlé et puis
avec nous en visioconférence j'accueille
vincent couronne qui est docteur en
droit public cofondateur des surligneurs
bonsoir c'est un collectif de juristes
qu'on va retrouver régulièrement dans
séance publique puisque vous êtes
partenaires de public sénat pour cette
campagne présidentielle vous passez
notamment les promesses des candidats au
tamis de leur réalisme juridique on
appelle ça en bon français du legal
checking bienvenue à vous et puis
laetitia culpa évidemment éditorial
politique qui est toujours à mes côtés
ce chiffre de 19 morts en moyenne par an
déjà ça vous a fait réagir
bon maintenant je suis comme je suis
invité je suis très polis
non mais cette année c'est cette mort
donc c'est cette mort de trop hockey et
c'était 11 l'année dernière alors je
veux bien qu'on fasse le cumul des deux
mais je sais pas où on a trouvé 19 morts
sur plusieurs années
les verts sont très doués enfin le total
ces 400 420 morts sur les vingt
dernières années sont être honnête c'est
ainsi que ça fait quand même c'est un
peu artificielle comme calcul bien sûr
ça fait autant de morts de trop les 80
10% sur des chasseurs je vous le
rappelle quand même et le situation
c'est qu'effectivement on a réussi en 15
ans a serré la vis au maximum pour que
les gens comprennent et un meilleur
comportement et aujourd'hui ça commence
à fortement marché parce que on va pas à
la chasse avec la peur au ventre désolé
mais par contre il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ne vont pas se balader et qui ont la
peur au ventre parce qu'ils ne sont pas
bien informés et ça c'est une partie de
notre tort c'est de ne pas avoir
correctement informé des gens qui
viennent à la campagne sans avoir un
cousin un frère ou un oncle qui peut
expliquer et dont il entend d'un coup de
fusil se disent on peut pas aller alors
qu'on peut aller dans 80% du territoire
lorsqu'on chasse on va parler du poids
politique du poids électoral de poids
sociétal des chasseurs évidemment dans
cette dans cette émission guillaume
montas comment vous le percevez je
disais on est à un million de cartes de
chasse mais quand on répond c'était une
enquête qui avait été faite au mois de
février question posée aux français est
ce que vous êtes chasseur il ya 5
millions de personnes qui ont possédé un
permis dans leur vie donc ça représente
quand même un poids électoral majeur
wybo le poids électoral je veux dire on
n'est pas là pour fonctionner comme ça
moi je voudrais quand même répondre sur
la question du nombre de morts un mort
c'est un mort de trop surtout à
moi aussi j'veux dire
moi je le dis je la firme parce que dans
mon territoire sur le plateau de
belledonne à côté d'eux à côté de
grenoble quand on a une personne qui se
baladent sur un chemin de grande
randonnée qui n'a rien qui n'a rien
demandé qui décèdent parce qu'il s'est
pris une balle
je suis désolé on peut pas l'accepter et
donc moi quand on me dit le risque zéro
n'existe pas je suis désolé ici pour les
personnes qui vont se promener ils ne
doivent pas pouvoir se prendre une balle
entièrement d'accord c'est tout donc non
mais voilà où deux rigoler
je rigole pas sur la mort parce que nous
on va voir les gens et faire on fait
notre boulot mais désolé c'est un ou
deux morts par la chasse et moi ce que
je ne souhaite comme vous faites c'est
de ne pas opposer chasseurs et non
chasseurs a bien marché mais chez moi
j'ai jamais eue on a aucun problème là
dessus moi je suis un géant des mers de
plus de 200 habitants avec une assez ca
je sais exactement de quoi il s'agit mon
grand-père était chasseur donc on va pas
me la faire donc ça là dessus c'est bon
par contre de pouvoir aller se promener
tranquillement en campagne effectivement
c'est pas besoin que ce soit un frère ou
un beau frère ou un autre ça peut être
aussi des personnes féminines qui
peuvent aller aussi se promener parce
que c'est vrai que la chasse est quand
même très masculins 1 98% de chasseurs
donc voilà je pense que cette nature
cette appropriation de la nature par
tout le monde elle est importante elle
est allée 1 p et moi je pense que c'est
aussi dans l'intérêt des chasseurs et
c'est vrai que j'entendais widi chaîne
je trouve que c'est c'est hallucinant la
manière dont ils wish à nos gestes
schéma pas son nom ce que je trouve
tellement hallucinant
la fédération de la chasse la manière
dont il part de la chasse je suis désolé
moi je vous dis je suis pas là pour
opposer les gens
position à rediscuter
tout le monde bat frédéric dans l'essai
sais quoi dans notre imaginaire
collectif la chasse voir revenir là
dessus dans notre imaginaire collectif
la chasse et déjà c'est un sujet facile
qui permet de cliver tout le monde on va
le voir certains artistes comme
d'habitude et on va pas avancer enfin en
tout cas j'ai la chasse c'est que nous
on essaye dans cette image je sais bien
thomas je sais bien c'est la chasse dans
notre imaginaire collectif c'est la
révolution c'est l'abolition des
privilèges le 4 août 1789 et ça c'est
unique en europe c'est aussi pour ça
qu'en france la chasse est un sujet
complexe est un sujet important un poids
politique important les autres pays
n'ont pas connu ça l'abolition des
privilèges s'est traduite par
l'autorisation de chasser le droit de
chasser et ensuite c'était un ou deux
ans après immédiatement borné par
mirabaud qui constatant que le droit de
chasser avait été utilisé avec folie par
les paysans qui se sont vengés sur le
gibier qui était l'apanage de la royauté
donc il y avait plus rien à chasser y
avait même plus une forêt tellement
n'avait coupé ça aussi c'est un apanage
de la royauté qu'on a à dos et le droit
de chasser au droit de propriété mais
ensuite on a mis le permis de chasse
1810 je crois napoléon donc c'est
foncièrement liées à sap et c'est
foncièrement lié à notre histoire de
pays qui n'est devenu aussi
industrialisés que son principal
concurrent anglais que dans les années
30 on est pile foncièrement rural qui
fantasment largement ses racines rurales
on est un pays
toujours héritiers de façon vive allant
de la révolution à la fois
révolutionnaire et monarchistes on aime
aussi la chasse à courre qui est aussi
une forme de restitution de ce qui se
passait avant et puis les chasserons la
ruralité pour ce que j'en connais dans
les endroits où il ya plus rien il ya
même plus un boucher une poste il reste
les associations de chasse qui sont là
bas qui sont là et qui sont là aussi
qu'ils sont presque des auxiliaires
public parce que ils connaissent le
territoire parker ouais ça on va le
détailler ici mais ces sept questions de
ruralité ruralité et chasse vous vivez
dans un village rural en isère qu'est ce
que moi j'ai une réalité positive
heureusement que la rivalité c'est pas
ça et qui reste plus qu'une association
de chasse
la réalité c'est que dans les
associations chasse on a plus que 8 %
d'agriculteurs qui sont qui sont
chasseurs moi je le vois chez moi la
plupart des chasseurs viennent le
week-end plutôt des zones plutôt du
zones urbaines plutôt des cadres il
reste quelques uns oui j'ai quelques
vérités en france et passe à gauche des
verts c'est dommage il suffit de
regarder le pourcentage de chasseurs
secoirs mais
chassez c'est devenu un quoi un loisir
de csp + est ce que vous êtes en train
de toute façon on est bien quelque chose
comme ça c'est que depuis 2000 europa
par an quand même pas l'avoir chassé
laissez pas
les autres si vous êtes si vous êtes
dans une petite commune jeu ça
m'attriste quand même le permis de
chasse il est à 130 euros 130 euros pour
un département et d'ailleurs mais je /
devenir miss nationale il est à 200
euros donc en clair pour 200 euros + 50
euros sur la carte communale de chasse
vous pouvez chasser pendant cinq mois de
l'année le fusain des cartouches non
mais le fusil vous l'achetez pour votre
vie et éventuellement si vous prenez
celui de votre père ou d'autres grands
pères ou de votre grand-mère pardonnez
moi j'ai dû
au moyen âge élevé on mais quand c'est
sa seule passion objectivement je dis
bien aucun problème parce que c'est un
petit peu rural dans la plupart des cas
que c'est une activité très populaire
avec des ouvriers des chômeurs des
retraités c'est une évidence et soyons
clairs voilà merci c'est la réalité
les verts moi je suis attristé
la réalité c'est quoi et 35 c'est que la
charité la chasse ce n'est pas tu me
joue ce n'est pas la glace en
agriculteurs et la sologne branche
assainies l'alsace ni la sologne où il
ya des patrons du cac 40 peu et des gens
comme ça l'avancé dans ce débat laetitia
quand on dit chasse et politiques vous
pensez aux chasses présidentielles
alors j'ai pas été regarder dans le
détail et dans les pourcentages mais oui
les chasses présidentielles ont toujours
existé parce qu'il ya une petite
comme ça dans l'inconscient collectif et
puis qui a été relayé aussi par tout le
monde que jacques chirac et nicolas
sarkozy
or est interdit ces chasses
présidentielles les aurait transformé
écoutez thomas peut être officiellement
oui mais officieusement il ya toujours
eu ces chasses présidentielles et c'est
carrément du domaine de la diplomatie
pourquoi parce que depuis de gaulle qui
tenait pas à grand chasseur il avait
décidé qu'à rambouillet pourrait se
retrouver des chefs d'état
internationaux des grands patrons toutes
les figures du pouvoir finalement sur la
planète pouvait autour d'un bon repas
avec un fusil à la main et en chassant
discuter des enjeux prochain de
géopolitique et de l'histoire mondiale
et ça continue depuis pompidou c'est lui
qui a décidé de créer chambord et
ensuite valéry giscard d'estaing qui
était un grand chasseur lui aussi réuni
ses voiles à ses hôtes autour de cet art
de vivre français et ça a été comme ça
chaque les emmanuel macron lalala assumé
d'une certaine d'accord complètement là
il a complètement assumé je pense que
vous le connaissez très bien c'est parce
que venus williams est ce que vous le
voyez toute façon tout à fait régulière
enfin en tout cas vous savez
je suis même accusé d'avoir organisé les
40 ans à chambord voiliers et la venue
de des mânes de la crau tableau de
chasse il ya deux livres qui sont sortis
sur le sujet intéressant ses 40 ans à
chambord partager une photo qui a
effectivement fuite et d'emmanuel macron
avec des chasseurs dans la nuit pour une
battue au sanglier il me semble je suis
spécialiste est le tableau de chasse et
le tableau c'est à la fin de la chasse
on remercie tout le monde mais c'est
aussi le moment où les chasseurs assume
une réalité c'est dire qu'on a tué des
animaux donc on est devant les animaux
mais en remercie les traqueurs pas s'ils
ont des chiens est à dire que la chasse
elle s'est pas fait tout seul et c'était
la première fois depuis 40 ans qu'un
président de la république assumer le
fait de venir à ce moment là sur tableau
de chasse gardée à assumer il ya une
photo qui a été prise
en campagne électorale on va on va ré
écouter ce qu'ils nous le disaient en
2017 et oui c'était très très clairs
écouter ses terres mars 2010
dans ce qu'il faut laisser respirer les
gens
donc pu et
je crois que c'est juste mon bijou qui
avait eu cette phrase en disant moi
c'est miss arrêtez d'emmerder les
français je pense qu nettement on a
beaucoup mieux à faire qu'à aller
chercher les gens sur tout les chefs
traditionnels qui existe un ça fait
partie en effet du patrimoine ça fait
partie de l'art de vivre ça fait partie
aussi d'un temps qu'on organise d'un
rapport à la nature c'est aussi moi qui
ont diffusé batteur un lien la
littérature et nos traditions parce que
ce sont des chats ce dont on parle
les uns dans pagnol les autres dents
jaunes voix et eager et donc je ne suis
pas pour qu'on les arrête je ne suis pas
pour qu'on les ait fait pas ça fait
partie du patrimoine français bon c'est
un peu caricatural en termes de
vocabulaire et de positionnement dans la
communication politique mais bon
pourquoi pas hein ce marché est ce que
donc vous n'avez pas répondu à ma
question vous êtes toujours proche de
lui vous êtes son conseiller chasse aux
pins ont conseillé tout court oui je le
conseille depuis le début j'étais le son
conseiller ruralité chasse pendant la
campagne et j'espère continuer jusqu'au
bout la prochaine campagne que j'assume
complètement bien sûr mais au-delà de ça
la réalité ce qui mène au lac rond et
picard et quand on connaît un peu les
racines picarde on peut habiter au
centre ville d'amiens la chasse c'est
quelque chose de très fort c'est quelque
chose emmanuel lacroix toujours dit la
chasse saignant sport ni un loisir c'est
un mode de vie il est pas sa soeur mais
ya énormément de gens qui défendent la
chasse sans jamais être chasseur parce
qu'ils comprennent cette espèce de de
défense de la ruralité mais aussi qu'ils
comprennent cette passion cet art de
vivre ce côté mois certes on va pas
polémiquer mais honnêtement moi la
chasse pour moi c'est un bonheur et pour
beaucoup de gens c'est un équilibre
personnel sur un territoire rural et on
n'en fait pas non plus au départ
il ya plein de manières de trouver son
équilibre et je trouve que monsieur fait
très bien son métier il est lobbyistes
on voit il a joué son rôle donc parfait
moi j'ai rien à dire le jour où j'ai pas
le président de la fédération de vtt la
même écoute auprès auprès des malades
mettront à ses 7000 17 millions de de
vététistes le jour le président de la
fédération des randonneurs en montagne
pourra aussi avoir cette même écoute
mais je suis quand même assez étonné de
la place que peut prendre la chasse moi
je suis absolument pas là pour
polémiquer moi le fait que via des
chasseurs j'ai aucun problème là on est
sur une question de de huy de risque une
vraie problématique qui n'est pas
anodine et une pétition sur le site du
sénat en à peine une semaine sans 1100
milles et ses 120 dollars mi journée à
122 me encore compteur a été arrêté
j'étais en conférence des présidents
tout à l'heure on a décidé de poursuivre
il va y avoir une mission d'information
au sénat sur ces questions sur ces
questions de partage de la nature deux
jours sans chasse de sécurité de la
question des désarmements aussi et qui
va être très large c'est ce que nous a
dit la présidente de la commission en
présence de gérard chez donc moi pour
l'instant je suis très satisfait que ça
puisse s'ouvrir parce que oui je pense
qu'il faut le mettre tout le monde
autour de la table aborder ce problème
sereinement et ouais je pense que vous
verrez on va y arriver et on va trouver
ce partage et je pense qu'à un moment
donné où il faut un temps pour que des
gens puissent aussi appréhender la
nature de manière si
je sais pas si c'est
à cette question par laëtitia mais elle
va venir après la chronique de style
jourdain qui justement s'appuie sur sur
cette pétition et plus généralement 6
rebonds soit sur un sujet voilà dans le
sénat voilà c'est inspiré car les
hackers voilà un sujet qui tient à coeur
ici au palais du luxembourg le groupe
chasse et pêche l'un des groupes les
plus courus ici en quelque sorte les
plus puissants du parlement il faut en
être un clairement thomas elf en est
d'autant plus souvent que dans leur
département les sénateurs sont
confrontés souvent aux chasseurs aux
différents lobbys de la chasse qui leur
demande des comptes sur le terrain flash
back peut être thomas décembre 2020 dans
le lot un jeune homme de 25 ans morgane
keane je sais pas si vous en rappelez
morgan qui me coupe du bois dans son
jardin il est mortellement touché par un
tir par le tir d'un fusil de chasse le
responsable c'est un chasseur qui
participait à une battue et qui avaient
cru identifier un sanglier à la suite de
cet accident les proches de morgan qui
décide de lancer une pétition
précisément vous en parliez guillaumont
tard sur le site internet
du sénat elle est mise en ligne début
septembre elles demandent plusieurs
choses cette pétition à l'interdiction
de la chasse le mercredi et le dimanche
de le renforcement des règles de
sécurité au pian et puis encore un
meilleur contrôle des armes de chasse la
pétition qu on connait vous l'avais dit
à un succès fulgurant à tel point
qu'avant même avant même le seuil des
cent mille signatures le sénat annonce
saisir de la pétition traduction sénat
décide de créer une mission
d'information sur ce sujet de la chasse
il va concrètement travailler sur place
alors la mission de cette mission
d'information c'est d'examiner la
question de la sécurité à la chasse la
sécurité de chacun en période de chasse
sophie primas sénatrice les républicains
à l'origine de cette mission ne veut pas
de polémique politicienne à l'approché
de l'élection présidentielle on les
écoute
de s'éloigner de l'émotion des
différents accidents qui a lu très
récemment cette commission elle
comportera tous les groupes politiques
et on va essayer de vraiment travailler
sur un sujet non polémique qui est
partagée d'ailleurs par les chasseurs et
les non chasseurs qui est celui de la
sécurité et encore une fois on ne veut
pas être l'otage des élections
présidentielles alors sur le fond thomas
les sénateurs disent n'exclure aucune
piste toutes les options sûres sont sur
la table nous assure-t-on c'est ce
qu'assure donc les membres de la mission
d'information même officiellement
l'interdiction de la chasse les
mercredis et les dimanches merci steve
pour pour ces détails et ses
explications je me tourne maintenant
vers vincent couronne donc je rappelle
que vous êtes docteur en droit public
cofondateur des surligneurs donc votre
job c'est de passer au crible les idées
les propositions de campagne les
promesses des candidats sous l'angle
juridique c'est de cette idée
d'interdire la chasse un jour par
semaine qui détient ce pouvoir est ce
que est ce que c'est crédible
tout à fait possible maintenant il faut
savoir effectivement qui peut faire ça
ça relève clairement du parlement
donc les écologistes qui porte ce genre
de propositions s'ils veulent pouvoir
interdire la chasse ce dimanche il faut
d'abord être élu et puis ensuite avoir
une majorité à l'assemblée nationale
pour cela c'est une proposition
d'ailleurs la part des écologistes qui
n'est pas nouvelle parce que il avait
déjà proposé lors des élections
municipales mais aussi des élections
régionales sauf que ce n'est pas
possible un maire ne peut pas interdire
la chasse ce dimanche d'ailleurs on voit
qu'à lyon un maire écologiste qui
promettait d'interdire la chasse ce
week-end a été élu et n'a pas interdit
la chasse le week-end ou simplement
parce qu'il ne peut pas certains états
en europe quand même un interdisent la
chasse certains jours de la semaine le
royaume uni l'italie le portugal etc les
pays bas la france avait par une loi
déjà interdit la chasse le mercredi
c'était en 2000 et les chasseurs en
contrepartie avait obtenu la
réautorisation de certaines chasses
traditionnelles
mais en 2003 le parlement est revenu sur
ses pas et à ré autoriser la chasse ce
mercredi tout en maintenant ses chasses
traditionnelles pour les chasseurs donc
je dirais que c'est plutôt bien joué
pour les chasseurs mais certaines
espèces sont peut-être un peu retrouvé
le dindon de la farce c'est bien
utiliser des expressions animalière
merci je reviens vers vous évidemment
dès qu'on a besoin de votre expertise
juridique
vincent couronne guillaume gothard vous
avez apporté votre soutien 7 à cette
pétition je reste sur cette thématique
de voilà d'interdire un jour la chasse
un jour par semaine est ce que c'est ce
que prioritairement ce que vous voulez
on est déjà sur cette pétition c'est
vrai que c'est venu du décès de morgane
qui n'a été tué dans son jardin et je
trouve justement le fait qu' un
collectif qui soit monter un jour un
chasseur et
est encore une fois qu'ils ont eu cette
intelligence de ne pas rentrer dans la
polémique alors que je pense qu'il
aurait pu mais de poser sa de faire des
propositions d'utiliser un biais qui
était ouvert sur le site du sénat moi je
trouve ça particulièrement intelligent
et donc voilà il va falloir qu'on
s'appuie là-dessus moi il me semble que
c'est indispensable c'est à dire qu'à un
moment donné oui il ya des pratiques et
qui ont évolué aussi c'est à dire que je
vois c'est un secteur de montagne de
moyenne montagne beaucoup de randonneurs
beaucoup de vététistes on a de plus en
plus l'utilisation de la montagne
devient même une problématique sur la
sur fréquentation et donc on doit on
doit réfléchir aussi par rapport à ça et
sur ce partage de la nature et donc il
me semble indispensable qu'à un moment
donné il ya un espace alors est-ce que
c'est samedi est ce que c'est le
dimanche c'est le mercredi est-ce que
c'est l'ensemble du week-end où tous tes
vacances scolaires je dirais que pour
l'instant justement moi je pense qu'on
va avoir ce débat cette réflexion là
mais en tout cas qui à un moment où on
puisse faire des activités sans avoir
cette crainte cette peur vous me dites
c'est pas justifié cetera peut-être mais
de savoir qu'on se promène sur un chemin
de grande randonnée que peut-être il ya
une battue pas loin que peut-être il ya
des chasseurs qui sont là et que je
risque pour ma vie parce que c'est une
réalité je pense que c'est pas
acceptable et donc quand une fois c'est
pas pour ou contre la chasse et comment
on partage ses différentes activités
moment partagé la nature tient à un
élément un sondage réalisé par ipsos qui
ça date du mois de septembre dernier sur
l'encadrement de la chasse la question c
faut-il encadrer plus strictement la
chasse la réponse c'est oui pour 6
personnes sur 10 frédéric dans et c'est
quoi votre point de vue là dessus cette
idée de partage de la nature est ce que
les chasseurs devraient un peu lâché du
lest enquête oui je pense parce que
sinon les chasseurs vont donner
l'impression n'ont pas compris que la
société avait changé pour deux raisons
la première trois raisons la première
c'est que de plus en plus de randonneurs
de vététistes et c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
envie de prendre un risque
qui ne vient pas d'eux mêmes il ya plus
de morts chaque année parmi les
randonneurs de haute montagne sauf que
je serai bus il tente point c'est tout
c'est pas du tout les jeux moi j'étais
plongeurs j'ai pris tous les risques
dans la plongée profonde mais si je
mourais c'était de ma faute est vraiment
bien sociaux c'était ma décision là avec
la chasse même si le risque est faible
il existe quand même et la tolérance au
risque d'être notre société elle est
quasiment nul c'est la même tolérance
vis-à-vis de tous les affres de la vie
c'est à dire qu'on est dans une société
étrange on tolère plus la douleur la
souffrance la mort fin bref la vie et
les haies et les chasseurs symbolise
finalement une absence d' hypocrisie en
fait il nous renvoie notre propre
hypocrisie eux assument la mort assume
de la donne et assume finalement tous
les tourments de la vie on leur reproche
ça mais faut qu'ils l'intègrent il faut
qu'il intègre d'autant plus que
aussi des pratiques qu'on veut plus voir
enfin moi personnellement le déterrage
de blaireaux et des renards j'ai plus
envie de le voir mois la chasse à courre
me dérange pas la chasse me dérange pas
ça s'évacue par exemple oui enfin c'est
déjà un terrain en fait c'est toujours
la même chose c'est interdit les chasses
traditionnelles les chasseurs disent oui
mais non le prélèvement est faible c'est
pas la question c'est que c'est une
chasse qui est non sélectif c'est à dire
que on risque de prendre une autre
espèce peut être une espèce protégée
alors qu'on espérait cibler une autre
c'est chasselas à mon avis faut les
faire disparaître parce que sinon c'est
toute la chasse qui va disparaît en
termes de communication c'est
complètement nul les chasseurs imagine
que mais non c'est pas grave il se
replie sur des indices sur des
statistiques ils oublient que face à eux
il ya un receveur dans un dans un
message d'un émetteur il ya un receveur
et le receveur n'est plus capable de
recevoir ce message dernière chose les
populations rurales change aussi elle se
renouvelle et c'est ce qui fait peur
beaucoup aux chasseurs il ya un problème
de transmission aujourd'hui dans les
familles de chasseurs il ya des enfants
qui ne veulent plus chasser parce qu'il
respecte les animaux qu'elle est néo
ruraux qui s'installe et qui ont une
autre vision des choses et fait lé
travail et c'est la grande peur que je
sens moins chez les chasseurs c'est de
voir tous leurs imaginaires en train de
disparaître par un changement de la
société thierry costes alors ça c'est
une question très générale le changement
de la société française est votre
perception face à ce changement vous
pouvez réagir à ça puis après on
reviendra sur un jour de chasse hunting
ou pas je vais être obligé de réagir à
plusieurs choses parce qu'il espère bien
on a dit on a dit plein de choses qui
sont très intéressantes la réalité on
peut dire que effectivement les
chasseurs ont peur du changement limay
de l'évolution de nos sociétés on n'a
jamais depuis cinq ans vu autant de gens
qui s'inscrivaient pour permis de
chasser ce qui est notre propre surprise
parce qu'on passe un examen pour aller à
la pêche on paye on utilise on tape sur
internet on prend sa carte on va pêcher
et il ya déjà des pêcheurs y en avait un
million deux maintenant il ya un million
sacs chez les chasseurs et ben ali notre
grande surprise depuis quatre ans on a
un afflux de gens de jeunes de femmes de
gens qui ont 30 à 40 ans qui viennent
qui arrive à la campagne ou qui
reviennent à la campagne et qui disent
tiens c'est une occasion de se
sociabiliser très vite parce que c'est
une occasion de partager la nature sa
symphonie sujet inquiète sur la place de
la chan on n'est pas une autre raison
pendant c'est qu'on n'a pas attendu ni
les morts ni les verts pour dialoguer
avec les autres utilisateurs de la
nature on n'est quand même pas
totalement décréta des blues ni mauvaise
mais on a on a quand même énormément de
dialogue avec toutes les fédérations de
randonnée de vtt
d'équitation bien évidemment on a même
créé pendant pendant le confinement une
alliance des sports et loisirs de nature
où il ya la chasse la pêche c'est aussi
le golf l'équitation le vtt la randonnée
pourquoi la flamme on la montagne les
fédérations de la montagne bien problème
parce qu'on a un besoin de dialoguer
bien évidemment on n'a jamais dit qu'il
fallait chasser tous les jours pendant
cinq mois par an ça n'existe pas pendant
longtemps on a eu un débat sur le
mercredi jour de chasse alors que les
chasseurs avaient de même le mardi et le
vendredi ils interdisaient la chasse
dominique voynet ayant voulu durcir le
système je vous interromps parce qu'il
nous reste assez peu de temps pardon
hein
moi j'essaie de vous à de vous expliquer
qu'on dialogue et que vous avez pu
remarquer pendant toutes les polémiques
vous avez eu une fédération de loisirs
de nature nationale qui a pris une
position pour le soutien la mesure des
verts pas du tout parce que la réalité
c'est qu'on doit dialoguer et que quand
on dialogue aujourd'hui
dans les forêts domaniales est la chasse
est interdite de week-end c'est quoi le
problème que ce serait pas le moment de
effectivement accepté qu'un jour deux
voleurs machine mais
on est très contents de la mission
sienne à la loi en 2003 et en 2005
existe parce qu'on va on va nous aussi
faire des propositions
c'est une évidence mais la chasse c'est
pas la chasse c'est les chasses quand
vous êtes en forêt domaniale à côté
d'une ville l'achat se fait 25 ans qu'il
est interdite le samedi et dimanche
c'est dans le cahier des charges les
chasseurs qui chasse la le savent mais
au fin fond de la lozère quand y'a
personne ce serait légitime que les
chasseurs continue à chasser le samedi
et le dimanche dans d'autres cas parce
qu'il ya des sentiers de randonnée une
proposition une sorte de de
décentralisation des règles c'est ça
mais bien évidemment il faut s'adapter à
la situation quand vous avez des
sentiers de grande randonnée qui peuvent
poser des problèmes parce qu'il ya
énormément de gens qui vont alors la
randonnée n'est pas un problème c'est un
vrai sujet donc on s'adapte il ya des
endroits où mme au moment des vacances
scolaires autour des stations de ski eh
bien désolé on ne chasse pas ni l'été ni
l'hiver parce que il ya des touristes
alors qu'on peut chasser en août et en
septembre des animaux à la proche mais
bien évidemment les mesures doivent être
adaptées pour quoi il est mort en 2000 à
quel moment parce que si le mercredi
c'était interdit qui a besoin d'attirer
cause le lobby des chasseurs
c'est pas compliqué on fait changer la
loi madame aimé quand ben en 2003 quand
la droite est revenue au pouvoir
d'accord et du coup vous avez toutes
obtenues donc en tenant hors faut être
honnête le texte qui a été obtenue le
texte de
2010 est attendu mercredi jour de nos
chats ce qui était un épouvantail agité
par les chasseurs j'en était le
porte-drapeau et je suis pas sûr qu'on
ait fait la chaussée avenue malines
pourquoi est ce parce que dans la
réalité pourtant devoir éliminer la
chasse la ca doit analyser pour ça
c'était juste que ce que je retiens est
ce que je comprends c'est que vous le
regrettez quelque part puisque vous
venez de nous expliquer de nous dire
qu'effectivement il y avait un bail
avait le jour où il y avait un nom mais
vous venez d'expliquer je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec d'ailleurs lorsque ce
que vous disiez sur les chemins de
randonnée sur les les espaces de grande
fréquentation ya des vrais ya des vraies
problématiques et oui elle existe on a
cette évolution aussi du nombre de
personnes qui sont qui sonde qui sont
assez dur mais on a une évolution sur le
type d'armement aussi avec des armes
beaucoup plus puissantes et donc qui
pose un problème non moi le cas par
exemple en ille et vilaine c'est une
c'est une vraie problématique aussi âpre
à côté d'une route on peut se demander
alors à chaque fois oui c'est pas voilà
mais n'empêche que ben il ya une
personne qui est désunie et
ensuite à chaque fois de parler de
polémique moi je ne vois pas de
polémique je vois juste un sujet qui
tourne qu elle il faut s'emparer pour
trouver des solutions le sait on est là
donc arrêter de parler de polémique en
permanence
décennale c'est jadot qui annonce la
polémique c'est nous qui sommes mais
pourquoi le chariot ça serait une
polémique nous apporte une solution
comme tout candidat à la présidentielle
et le sénateur avait chanté par tirer
comme et le sénat s'est emparé du sujet
des actions citoyennes ici on est dans
un espace qu'on essaye de de s'écouter
de parler calmement et donc je voudrais
moi faire avancer le débat autour de ce
que willy schraen le président de la
fédération des des chasseurs a proposé
ce partenariat aux élus ruraux pour
lutter contre la délinquance rural et
environnemental confié aux chasseurs une
police de proximité et je reviens vers
vincent couronne de des surligneurs
comment vous l'analysez jury est ce que
juridiquement c'est réaliste cette
proposition
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est
peut-être une proposition qui pourrait
concilier vos intervenants vos
débatteurs sur le plateau c'est
peut-être un peu contre intuitif mais
c'est une proposition qui est possible
les certains chasseurs ou déjà
d'ailleurs des pouvoirs de police c'est
ce qu'on appelle des agents de
développement c'est les anciens gardes
fédéraux c'est comme ça qu'on les
appelait auparavant ils sont agréés par
le préfet et y dispose de certains
pouvoirs pour constater par exemple dd
je sais pas moi c'est des questions sur
le vérifier les quotas de prélèvement il
vérifie les permis de chasse et c est ce
que propose willy schraen c'est
d'élargir leur pouvoir de police
ce dont je ne parlais ce sont déjà des
pouvoirs de police mais les pouvoirs de
police administrative
on peut très bien le leur confier tant
que ça ne ça ne grignote pas en quelque
sorte sur les pouvoirs de police
judiciaire c'est à dire réprimer des
infractions des infractions pénales
alors qu'est ce qu'on pourrait leur
confier comme pouvoir vérifier par
exemple contrôler le respect de
certaines règles environnementales
pourquoi pas dans dans les forêts etc
c'est une c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait être fait
et puis
lorsqu'on ce qu'on pourrait également
leur confier c'est le respect de
d'autres d'autres réglementations sur la
biodiversité par exemple ou encore l'
autre chose donc ça c'est tout à fait
possible peut être formé pour ça
mais tant que encore une fois ça ne
s'invente pas sur les pouvoirs de police
judiciaire on ne peut pas arrêter
quelqu'un le menotter l'amener au
commissariat ou à la gendarmerie ce
n'est pas possible et c'est vrai que
c'est une solution qui pourrait
permettre de pallier des atteintes à
l'environnement dans des communes
rurales qui manque peut-être de
personnel pour cela merci merci va
s'offrir exemple comment vous analysé
cette cette proposition est est ce que
vous vous l'imaginez réaliste peut-être
en nous donnant des informations sur les
liens entre les chasseurs et les élus
ruraux parce que ça c'est un élément
important sur la proposition de willy
schraen sais pas si c'est vous qui lui
avait glissé dans l'oreille c'est un
coup de génie en terme de com parce
qu'il viendrait combler un trou qui est
celui d'une fonction qui existait avant
qu'il n'existe quasiment plus et celle
des gardes champêtres est un peu entre
la police municipale et la police
nationale qui avait des pouvoirs étendus
et qui avait le mérite de régler en fait
été un peu d une juridiction civile à
deux pieds qu'ils étaient capables
d'identifier d'auditionner de signaler
de faire la paix sociale à l'échelle
rural et de repérer tout ce qui n'allait
pas et comme l'état n'assure plus la
police de l'environnement parce qu'il a
créé le fbi impliquant du fric aux
agences de l'eau mais en ne finançant
pas cette police de l'environnement eh
bien il ya un trou à combler que comble
déjà en partie certaines fait des
chasses il doit y avoir trois ou quatre
mille chasseurs qui sont assermentés
voilà finalement c'est oui c'est pas une
proposition stupide alors même tout de
même qu'il existe cette fonction peut
guère de champêtre qui est tombé en
désuétude mais qui est parfois utilisée
il ya certaines communes qui réembauche
des gardes champêtres et ce serait loin
d'être bête en terme de com encore une
fois parce que les chasseurs comme les
naturalistes arpente le terrain
connaissent tout aussi bien que les
gendarmes et c'est aussi pour ça qu'ils
font peur que c'est un pouvoir un lobby
à l'échelle du département c'est parce
qu'ils connaissent tous et notamment ils
connaissent tous les élus qui sont
capables d'alerter très vite et c'est
aussi pour ça que les chasseurs avec les
naturalistes sont des éléments
fondamentaux pour créer certains
documents de planification comme les
trames verte et bleue parce qu'ils
connaissent le moindre bosquet donc
c'est loin d'être bête et c'est ça que
devrait être le débat sur la chasse moi
franchement ils datent de chargement fou
bas ce qui m'emmerde plus et le
déterrage de blaireaux du renard ces
chasses dégueulasse derrière la chasse
plutôt que ce voilà de ceux de jouer
cette comédie humaine là moi je
préférerais qu'on parle de biodiversité
de gestion de biodiversité la chasse à
sa place mais il faut surtout pas que
macro oublie que effectivement les
chasseurs sont un lobby bien identifiés
mais aussi un lobby qui n'existe pas qui
devrait exister c'est celui de la
biodiversité des naturalistes des
chercheurs qui travaillent sur la
biodiversité qui n'ont aucune existence
politique parce qu'il ne représente rien
il faudrait que ces deux-là travaillant
sans je termine comme ils travaillent
déjà ensemble à une échelle locale les
écolos françois hollande s'engueule avec
les chasseurs moi je les connais sur
place globalement les choses se passent
bien parce que dès lors qu'on a les deux
pieds dans les bottes on est bien obligé
de trouver des compromis mais ce genre
de débat de fatigue franchement un peu
un peu comme la cgt qui ne signe rien au
niveau national mais beaucoup de
blessures au niveau local bref je sais
pas pourquoi cette comparaison m'est
venue mais je pense que mais elle elle
est bien l épave sur cette idée de
d'auxiliaires de police ou de police de
proximité pourquoi vous les défendez
alors non il ya juste une petite erreur
sémantique il n'est pas question de que
les chasseurs deviennent des policiers
de la nature ce sont les agents de
développement des fédérations ses 300
personnes effectivement le constat était
que beaucoup de communes viennent
frapper à la porte des fédérations et
par des chasseurs pas des associations
communales de chasse pour dire on a
besoin de surveiller le territoire avec
cause des décharges à cause de toutes
les petites incivilités qui fatigue vous
connaissez bien le territoire on a plus
de garde champêtre mais on a pu aussi de
gardes particuliers qui ne peuvent
exercer que sur un territoire s'il vous
plaît est-ce qu'on peut conventionnés
avec vous et où lee chan a toujours dit
il à 18 agents dans son département il
ya une trentaine de départements qui ont
des âges en développement ce soient des
professionnels qui soit assermenté donc
ils font la moindre connerie on leur
retire tout ils peuvent même perdre leur
job donc c'est vraiment ce territoire là
c'est pour permettre d'avoir une bonne
vision du territoire pourquoi parce que
la garderie de le fils de la de l'office
de la biodiversité fait de moins en
moins de la police de la chasse et de la
pêche et que nous on a toujours se
demander tout le temps à avoir des
missions de police parce que quand on
gère correctement la nature n'a pas
envie qu'elle se dégrade et comme le
disait notre ami avec les écologistes
sur le terrain dans bien des cas on
s'entend très bien comme avec les
randonneurs ou les cavaliers donc il ya
des caricatures que moi je n'aime pas
trop mais si on peut débattre de la
biodiversité mais j'en suis le premier
toujours sur ce point particulier cette
proposition de wisches alors moi je
trouve ça totalement un totalement
hallucinant bien sûr qu'il ya des
fédéraux qui ont une autorisation et qui
peuvent effectivement faire quelques
quelques actions que ça que ça existe
d'ailleurs dans le cadre effectivement
de l'activité de l'activité de chasse ce
qui a été et ce qui a été proposé c'est
totalement c'est totalement hallucinant
je veux dire de te demander à des gens
armés faire sa demande une formation sa
demande voilà ccc pour moi tout en
totale en total décalage pour moi la
vraie problématique
je sais pas si je suis le débat vous
agacement il m'agace pas moi je pense
que que de réfléchir à toutes ses atouts
ses problématiques trouve ça plutôt
plutôt intéressant mais la vraie
problématique est là et et disent oui
l'eau nf par exemple c'est encore 500
emplois en moins pour les cinq
prochaines années oui c'est sûr qu'on
manque de personnes sur les sur les
territoires les agents dans les parcs
naturels régionaux
c'est pareil on a du mal à trouver donc
moi je pense que c'est vraiment là
dessus qu'il faut travailler sur à la
fois de la formation sur de l'engagement
mais je pense que les chasseurs doivent
rester à leur place c'est pas les gens
de développement c'est autre chose alors
on parle de salles a su pourquoi
c'est qu'on développe et qu'on ait
besoin de deux présences qu'on ait
besoin d'accompagner aussi pour les
communes je vais vous dire qu'un agent
aux vnf sur une copie en terme
d'accompagnement pour un maire c'est
particulièrement important il propose un
partenariat aux élus ruraux pour lutter
contre la délinquance rurale et
développe et la délation
il a été maladroit dans son propos je
vous dis oui assez mais c'est pas mal à
dos et pas maladroit on voit bien
dans les airs et quand on voit très bien
il veut rebondir de sécurité c'est
encore c'est notre connerie de
communication faudrait peut-être le
changer oui moi je pense que c'est pas
du tout
question je pense que c'est voulu et
c'est bien la vision que que peuvent
avoir je pense que que c'est que c'est
qu'on peut pas remplacer je dire la
gendarmerie oui elle a un intérêt il ya
un lien effectivement avec les maires
mais on n'est pas du tout sûr ceux avec
les chasseurs vie paye tous les ans 40%
de la police de l'eau et b sans jamais
commandé quoi que ce soit les chasseurs
payait avant 100% de l'office national
de la chasse et la faune sauvage les
1200 fonctionnaires c'est comme essayer
à 100% sur le budget est chassé
je veux bien mais à un moment donné
il faut aussi il faut aussi respecter
les règles je veux dire quand un
responsable de fédération de chasse
demandé à peine à ce qu'on ne respecte
pas les directives européennes comment
ils vont pouvoir contrôler du coup
l'application j'espère que ce que vous
le condamniez parce que c'est quand même
car ils ont des bas mais encore une fois
à tous les deux c'était enlevés at war
iii parce que vous l'avez essayé de
rapporter à joe dassin je suis pas
arrivé chez mais en tout cas dans un
débat national de les faire dialoguer et
merci à vincent couronne y avait trop
éclairage juridique évidemment et on
aura d'autres occasions sur d'autres
thèmes de retrouver les surligneurs
puisque c'est un partenariat qui va
durer pendant toute cette campagne
présidentielle merci laetitia de votre
présence comme chaque mardi et chaque
jeudi fric dans les jeux rappel le titre
de votre livre la chasse le vrai du faux
aux éditions delachaux et nièces les
deux mains